à
ces besoins days
avec ta carte
cobra tu
attends pas fini
tu veux savoir où tu es
coupal fantin oui toi peut lire sur les
lèvres oui d'accord est-ce que je peux
t'aider
qu'est ce que tu veux enlève le king
gones
du côté des canadiennes et mais
alors où
en haute montagne noire voilà ce soit ou
pas 15 en oeuvre
bon à moi oui c'est justement
notre la
non à tabac à la barre
haut notre dame des bleus ne tombait pas
de trains de nuit nationaux
mieux
changement
[Rires]
au four et pour
saurez
vous pourrez pour sa fourrure en
ânonnant pour aimer une expression du
désir
pour copuler
copuler allemands nommés n'ont pas moi
moi je vais pas que plus avec toi nantes
a pas de débat à m'amuser m'amuser va
détruire les filles années qu'on dit
qu'on va enfin donner
à kergrist rue et 1 défaite danseuses
danseurs
danseuses danseurs
de rue
et tu marches jusqu'à
tu marches
jusqu'à sainte catherine oui vous êtes
perdus
ok
ok je peux aller sur un village dans le
village
la supporter la vue l'aspect paul
william t non non non
comprenez pas c'est un accent j'ai un
accent je trouvais un acteur
pas moi
j'espère english attack parle français
voyant parle la même langue car lille où
je parle français ou ok ok
[Musique]